[Music]
4:76 has earned its share of criticism
since launch but one of its most glaring
faults is the lack of meaningful events
and interactions in its desolate
post-apocalyptic world presumably in
service of its multiplayer component
many of the compelling interactions from
earlier Fallout games which drove
relationship building and player agency
have been lost or filed away to audio
logs and diary entries in terminals
scattered across the irradiated West
Virgina wilderness unfortunately this
method of delivering quests and plot
just isn't all that engaging and it
wears out its welcome fast that said I
don't think the problems it's entirely
with the lack of other human characters
as many other video games have found
ways to be engaging and tell great
stories without using NPCs people are
disappearing No if you won't help me
I'll do it on my own
we're responsible for all this you take
everybody's gone to the rapture for
instance which adopts a particularly
clever approach to storytelling in the
post apocalypse you explore a curiously
desolate town learning about the complex
relationships between its inhabitants
their personalities and what went down
in their final days the game doesn't
have objective markers or a quest log
their only motivation to move forward is
your own intrigue which is fueled by
finding locations where short scenes
play out between characters depicted by
light echoes much like Fallout 76 these
are glimpses into a time that has
already passed but the clever visual
choice in having the vignettes performed
by people shaped like blobs coupled with
exceptional voice acting and show don't
tell writing makes unravelling just what
happened in this town far more
interesting than endless diary entries
and audio logs placing the scenes in the
very same curiously empty town locations
they first occurred grounds the
characters in their roles and
relationships which makes it feel very
much like you were there if the slower
burn of everybody's gone to the rapture
leaves you skeptical then let's pivot to
another game this time focusing on a
crew stuck together in the confines of
an interstellar installation
Homa the inhabitants of the spacestation
are long gone but the principle game
mechanic enables you to load up
conversations throughout the station and
watch holographic representations of the
characters interact these scenes can be
replayed fast forwarded investigated and
explored like a moving narrative diorama
again you don't interact with the
characters but you can watch their
relationships evolve and see how they
face issues solve problems and alter
allegiances in the face of disaster
using your own initiative you can
explore scenes as deeply as you want
which lets you witness a large handful
of downbeat and casual moments between
the characters which work to better
inform who they are and increase your
ability to empathize with them and their
plight this is taken to the next level
in another game which takes you out of
the shoes of a disaster investigator and
into those of an insurance auditor the
return of the Overton
Oh burden plays out like a massive game
of Master Mind you know that board game
with the pegs when examining a corpse
aboard the ER burden you use a creepy
pocket watch to view the final moments
of the crewmembers life each scene
begins with a brief audio only context
before revealing a tableau of the
unfortunate souls last moment the
tableaus are just that sprawling
unmoving dioramas for you to walk in and
around in an effort to decipher who was
who what is happening at that moment how
they died
and ultimately what happened on the ship
the game's difficulty requires you to
pay close attention to unravel the
mystery and its unique art style and
twisty turny plot make you want to while
the quality of its story is divisive I
always really enjoyed the way the
division handled the post-apocalypse and
given this is the only other multiplayer
game on this list I think it's an
important parallel to fallout 76 the
world is almost devoid of friendlies
outside of the main base of operations
and a smattering of other player
characters but the division uses a
number of different methods to keep its
plot and the tails of its predeceased
characters engaging while the divisions
expositional survival guides are pretty
similar to the terminal end trace you'd
find in full at 76 there are also more
interesting collectibles which dole out
story in particular you can come across
echoes which are holographic
constructions with audio that are
superimposed over the existing
environment by highlighting the
physicality of the individuals in the
echoes as well as applying the use of
space in the environment you get a
better idea of where characters were
during these recorded moments which
increases the narrative impact of these
scenes the division also makes exploring
the post-apocalypse rewarding as you
gain medical tech and security supplies
for crossing off objectives these are
used to upgrade the base of operations
and make life better for the survivors
as well as upgrade your skills which
elevates your incentive
out there you'll need all your training
and equipment possibly I would have
loved any of the above ideas to be
peppered into fallout 76 accepting
perhaps the division and none of the
games I mentioned are trying to
incorporate as many different mechanics
as fallout 76 but it's worth exploring
that there are more interesting ways to
tell the stories of long gone and pcs in
476 the mechanics used to deliver quest
lines and story information are tedious
and easy to disconnect from there is
room for an engaging story that can be
experienced simultaneously by multiple
players like Diablo 3 or an empty post
apocalypse that tells the stories of its
long-gone inhabitants in a more
interesting way but that's not what we
got let me know down in that comment
section which games do you think could
do the post apocalypse or minimal
characters best and whether or not
you're a fan of the way for that 76
handles it for more on the game our
review and everything else I've
mentioned check back to GameSpot
[Music]
you
[Music]